sur le premier ministre patrice noël
joyeux noël à vous merci ce trudeau vous
allez bien vous avez une belle rencontre
avec monsieur le oui va parler avant
deux rencontres plus à fond dans
quelques minutes mais ç'a bien été
oui ça très bien et il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup d'enjeux sur lesquels on
s'entend à la merveille
on va parler du québec on va parler de
l'ouest on va parler d'environnement on
va parler de la chine je trudon mais
avant de parler d'avenir je vais vous
parler du passé ont vu revenir à
l'élection quelle leçon
vous avez tiré vous personnellement de
cette victoire en 2001 lequel vous avez
perdu des comptes et ça n'a pas été
facile
qu'est ce que c'est quelle est la leçon
vous avez conclu
pour moi c'est que les les on a vu sur
l'environnement sur l'économie sur les
investissements sur des aspects de
valeurs progressistes
il ya beaucoup d'alignement chez les
canadiens nés ils ont fait différents
choix en termes de partie je pense que
c'est clair qu'ils veulent qu'on
travaille ensemble qui est un une
collégialité qui n'avait peut-être pas
besoin d'exister en situation
majoritaire et vous vous la justin
trudeau le chef vous vous êtes dit bon
j'aurais dû être mieux pour ceux ci pour
cela est ce que vous êtes ce que j'ai un
examen de conscience chez vous que le
chef du monde mais je pense qu'il ya une
réflexion que j'ai eu c'est que 8 en
c'était beaucoup moins montbrun mon
identité qui a mené la lutte contenu sur
harper on avait d'excellents candidats
qui sont devenus d'excellents ministre
mais l'identité du gouvernement et est
beaucoup liée à
une identité personnelle et je pense
qu'à certains points ça nous a aidés à
certains points ça a été difficile et
l'image
il y avait passé moi l'expression mais
un buzz autour de oui tout à fait celle
fibre je me suis on avait fait une
entrevue dans le métro alma les gens se
précipiter sur vous
la jambe ça vaut bien plaisir ooyala
encore jour bonjour merci beaucoup
ben ça me fait plaisir oui écoute c'est
un aspect de la réalité que que que je
vis que nous vivons mais ça peut pas je
sais autour de moi le boss faut que ça
soit autour des accomplissements des
choses qu'on a fait de sortir des des
centaines de milliers d'enfants de la
pauvreté des des choses concrètes qui
des fois ne se voyait pas parce que tout
le monde me voyait alors ces deux
réflexions de commun mettant un peu plus
l'emphase sur le travail qu'ont connu le
contenu le travail le flafla ou moins et
l'image - l'image mais c'est que le
problème c'était que pas qu'on n'avait
pas de contenu c'est que ça se voyait
moins bien peut-être à cause de l'enjeu
images et maintenant on veut que les
gens s'aperçoivent de de ce qu'on a fait
de concret pour garder le canada sur la
bonne voie pour aider les québécois et
les canadiens ce truc dont on a vu hier
monsieur chez un autre chef c'est dur on
est sur un siège éjectable
est ce que maman dans la campagne soit
dans l'épisode du blackface ou dans
d'autres moments difficiles vous êtes
dit je t'ai pas fait pour ça je vais
démissionner je je je je n'aide pas
nécessairement mon parti est ce que vous
êtes penser là vous a traversé l'esprit
non non
vraiment non non j'ai eu des moments à
mon dieu que c'est difficile oh mon dieu
que quelques je m'en veux d'avoir fait
ceci ou de ne pas avoir fait cela mais
ce sentiment d'être d'être la personne
en ce moment qui pouvait rassembler
l'équipe est porté sur ce désir
collectif d'une que nous avons en tant
que parti de de bien servir le pays
non j'ai pas eu de doute à ce niveau-là
sujet des réflexions mon dieu ça ça va
durer combien de temps encore est ce que
j'en ai pas encore à 10 ans est ce que
j'en ai juste par rapport aux 2 3 mois
ou deux trois semaines
mais avez-vous vu eu peur de perdre ma
main certains jours je vais revoir à 30
et que les chats pic on est on est dans
une fiction on est toujours prêts à
aller prévu il faut et j'étais confiant
qu'on allait gagner mais il ya eu des
moments où howie une délicate étude que
ça l'est peut-être pas fallait pas finir
la bonne façon de la façon qu'on voulait
puis si un jour parce que vous êtes à la
tête d'un gouvernement minoritaire la
durée de vie en principe est plus court
si un jour vous apercevez que par
exemple dans l'ouest le nom de trudeau
ne passera jamais est ce que vous allez
pouvoir vous dire je m'en vais pour le
bien du parti ça je comprends que ya
beaucoup de préoccupations et beaucoup
de frustration dans l'ouest
et c'est facile par maman que certaines
régions où certaines populations s'en
prennent directement au gouvernement
fédéral il une historique là qui rend sa
facile de dire oui le problème c'est le
trudeau mais le problème c'est les
changements climatiques les problèmes
c'est la transformation de l'économie et
j'ai trop lui de bonnes conversations
avec des gens et clan des gens dans
l'ouest pour un blanc j'y prends la
série n'ont absolument pas parce que je
sais que les gens oui sont inquiets wii
sont frustrés mais je suis aussi que
nous avons la capacité de 100
très aidée et on va passer à travers on
va aller s'asseoir de ce trop dur on va
parler de tous ces sujets là avec un peu
plus de détails ce trudeau rebonjour
vous sortez d'une rencontre avec
françois legault la première rencontre
depuis votre élection
you infrastructures il hésitait beaucoup
la thur immigration laïcité prononcera
dans leur infrastructure est ce que vous
aviez des choses à lui annoncé à lui
dire on va vous faciliter la vie pour le
transfert d'argent on veut faciliter la
vie pour les investissements
d'infrastructure y ait des beaux projets
de transports collectifs dans lesquels
on votre partenaire on veut signer
l'entente sur le logement aussi que
c'est une préoccupation pour bien des
gens on a des milliards de dollars sur
la table pour les années à venir donc on
est là pour participer et évidemment il
ya toujours des petites petit niveau des
négociations alors pourra signer les
ententes mais un désir de travailler
ensemble qui est très positif ce qu'il
ya un déséquilibre pendant toutes les
complexités si ces techniques mais ce
que ya un désir de votre côté aussi de
simplifier les transferts d'argent
absolument nous on était élu sur une
promesse d'investir de façon concrète
dans les communautés dans le transport
collectif
on veut que ce soit bien fait mais on
veut aussi que ça se fasse rapidement
pour créer des emplois pour créer la
prospérité long terme
donc tout ce qu'on peut faire pour
accélérer le processus pour éviter le
dédoublement tout ça c'est des choses
sur lesquelles on s'entend très bien
immigration monsieur legault est en
demande vous le savez depuis plusieurs
mois le 40% que vous contrôlez les
réfugiés la réunification familiale de
québec dit nous on va en accueillir
moins parce qu'on veut plus de 2
d'immigration économique est ce que ça
vous lui donnez le cheval on entend à
travers le québec dans toutes les
régions lee
des préoccupations par rapport à la
pénurie de main-d'oeuvre à s'apprend oui
ça prend des travailleurs mais ça prend
aussi des familles pour venir
s'installer en région ça prend ça prend
plus que juste des personnes seules
la réunification sanyal ça fait partie
de sa trouver le bon équilibre on est
ouvert à ajuster ou à regarder ça mais
on sait que ça prend plus d'immigrants
pour créer une croissance économique les
êtes-vous vert à diminuer vos deux
catégories vous continuer à contrôler au
québec on serait on serait plus tôt vers
a augmenté d'au tres catégories les lui
ne veut pas monter trop haut on essaie
etc voilà les discussions qu'on est en
train d'avoir donc a pas eu de ya pas
une solution aujourd'hui à londres mais
on est on est pas en termes de
négociations on est en train de parler
de comment on va travailler ensemble
puis on est d'accord sur les bus
c'est juste une question de s'arranger
sur les mers moyens de le faire laïcité
il a dit on entre à la réunion qu'il
allait vous en parlez qu'est ce qui vous
a dit qu'est ce que vous lui avez dit
qu'est-ce qu'on avance où vous restez
sur vos positions et je pense que pour
pour nous deux cdc des positions de
conviction je pense que les québécois
savent très bien que pour moi la défense
des droits cs est primordial mais je
respecte aussi que c'est un gouvernement
qui a pris la décision qui a eu un
mandat pour le faire
c'est pour ça qu'on on regarde ça
regarde les citoyens qui compte est en
cours et nous on va pas intervenir pour
l'instant comme vous le savez bien
donc vous venez dire mais je reconnais
la juridiction du québec je reconnais le
désir d'un gouvernements légitimement
élus voulaient faire ceci donc vous avez
un peu cheminée quand même
non j'ai toujours reconnu que c'était
quelque chose que que le
le gouvernement trouvait qu'il y aurait
un mandat de faire mais moi je trouve
que le gouvernement fédéral a toujours
un mandat de veiller à ce que les droits
de tout le monde soit bien protégée et
c'est ce qu'on est en train de regarder
et le pour le fameux pour l'instant que
vous aviez donné la première journée de
la campagne électorale à quel moment
vous allez intervenir uniquement quand
ça sera devant la cour suprême je ne le
sais pas je ne le seront que j'ai pas
alors de le faire c'est pas quelque
chose que que à laquelle je pense
énormément mais je ne pourrais pas fermé
la porte à tout jamais à ce qu'un
gouvernement fédéral a et une position
sur les droits fondamentaux
ça va durer longtemps cette contestation
devant les tribunaux
pourquoi vous ne pourriez pas demander
une question à la cour suprême renvoie
la cour suprême est ce que c'est une
chose que vous pourriez faire écoute je
veux pas que ça devienne une lutte entre
le fédéral et la province
je veux que ce soit une réflexion de
sociétés is qui est en train de se faire
ici au québec c'est les gens de montréal
où une perspective différente que les
gens ailleurs au québec qu'ailleurs il
ya des conversations qui sont en train
de se faire il ya une question de
contestation devant la cour et et en
étendant tant québécois qui très
intéressés à ce qui se passe mais en
tant que gouvernement fédéral je veux
pas non plus créer des convoqués pas de
renvoi la gauche est prête pour
l'instant non je veux pas fermer portes
mais je veux pas non plus sombrer dans
l'hypothétique très bien l'aluminium
monsieur legault veut signer l'alena
contrairement au bloc qui veut
renégocier je pense qu'il le dit
clairement
cet après midi mais l'aluminium vous
n'avez quand même pas réussi à les
chercher les mêmes garanties pour
l'aluminium que les garanties pour
l'acier que les démocrates aux états
unis sont allés chercher
est ce que vous êtes triste douceur vous
êtes déçu de ça c'est sûr qu'on a on
voudrait toujours plus je pourrais vous
donner 10
différentes choses dans cette allen vous
auriez aujourd'hui aurait voulu un petit
peu plus mais il faut regarder dans
l'ensemble l'industrie de l'aluminium
comme un deal à l'industrie ce matin
c'est un bon accord c'est une
amélioration nette de sur ce qu'ils
avaient effectivement il ya des
différents engagements par rapport à
l'acier et pour l'aluminium
on passe de 1 0 % de contenu dans la
fabrique d'automobiles nord américaine à
1 70 % de contenu c'est une amélioration
énorme et c'est très bon pour notre
industrie nos travailleurs auxquels donc
pour vous ça va passer à ottawa il n'y a
pas de péril et 6 et des améliorations
et je pense que ça va passer ou non je
conviens que ça va passer le mieux vous
pouviez arraché monsieur de choix
c'est ce que vous dites clairement pour
que les gens comprennent je pense que
c'est un très bon accord on aurait été
un très bon accord avec n'importe quel
gouvernement américain avec sur vision
diffusion obama était difficile aussi la
dent dans différents différents enjeux
le fait qu'on ait pu arriver à un très
bon accord pour le canada et surtout le
fait d'avoir un accord est d'avoir un
accord qui a été appuyée et par les
démocrates et par les républicains sa
garantie qu'on va avoir accès aux états
unis pendant des générations encore à un
moment d'imprévisibilité et
protectionnisme dans le monde
ce trudeau l'ouest dans votre discours
du trône il ya pas une fois le mot
pétrole a été soulignée par jason kenny
mais même moi ça m'aurait on regardait
discours du trône mais pourquoi on
appelle pas un chat au canada vous savez
dans la grande région de montréal iott
230 mille voitures de plus aujourd'hui
qui en avait il ya 4 à une hypocrisie
générale au canada où on veut bien sûr
marché pour l'environnement pour on veut
que ça change
mais en même temps on conduit dv usb ma
question est ce que vous faites exprès
de
pas nommé le pétrole est ce que vous
voulez vraiment que les gens de l'ouest
vous en veille jusqu'à la fin des temps
au contraire on a parlé de bien des
choses mais il ya bien des choses dont
on n'a pas qu'on n'a pas de nommer
spécifiquement à l'inversé discours mais
on reconnaît que oui à des
préoccupations par rapport à l'industrie
des ressources naturelles et par rapport
à l'industrie du pétrole parce qu'avec
les changements climatiques
il va avoir des transformations des
économies mais nous on est un
gouvernement et je l'entends à tous les
jours de tous les bords oui en année un
prix sur la pollution
oui on a en a facilité l'achat et la
création d'un nouvel oléoduc parce qu'on
sait que on se doit de continuer à créer
cette croissance économique avec les
outils qu'on a maintenant en préparant
l'avenir qu'ils veuillent beaucoup plus
vert beaucoup moins polluant et cette
transition faut bien à gérer de façon
responsable
c'est sûr qu'il y en a de tous les bars
qui veulent plus d'un bon plus de l'eau
nous on a pris une position responsable
tout en faisant bien d'autres choses
aussi on a banni place
on est en train de bannir les places et
on est en train d'en finir avec les
centrales de charbon
on est en train d'agir de façon concrète
de façon ambitieuse mais de façon
responsable mais comment calmer cette
colère de l'ouest qui vous les gens vous
disent reconnaissait que l'industrie
pétrolière est une industrie importante
au canada qu'il ne faut pas avoir honte
de ce parce que bien sûr qu'on rêverait
au jour où il n'y en a plus il y en a
pour les missions qui vous dit faut plus
que rêver faut préparer ce jour-là faut
commencer à innover à transformer nos
économies pour le faire on a besoin des
experts en énergie de l'ouest justement
il va avoir des emplois pour les algues
vertes et pour les gens de saskatchewan
pour les gens qui innovent déjà dans
l'industrie de l'énergie
ça va se transformer petit à petit mais
nous la façon d'avancer c'est justement
de les rassurer que oui l'avenir veille
différents niveaux avoir une classe pour
eux ils vont avoir une place pour tout
le monde et on est prêt à faire les
investissements nécessaires pour qu'il
se voit
cet avenir là à cause de certaines
polémiques politiques qu'ils entendent
dans l'ouest ils voient pas le même dans
leur avenir
mais moi je suis en train de dire oui on
va trouver une amie en valais central
parce que vous faites le pipeline vous
allez aussi hongrois sursis en plus on
va aussi investir dans cette transition
investir dans l'énergie verte et
investir dans la protection de notre
notre territoire
il vous demande monsieur kahn est en
tête de d'adoucir les lois
environnementales si je résume et est ce
que vous allez le faire ce que vous
allez bien c'est là bas nous ce qu'on a
voulu faire avec la loi 69 c'est de
créer plus de certitudes pour
l'industrie mais aussi d'assurer une
approche vigoureuse sur l'environnement
et sur les lits les les peuples
autochtones parce que si on fait pour ça
si on raconte prend des raccourcis sur
l'environnement sont les provinces vous
demande oui si on fait des raccourcis et
environnement ont fini en cours et on
finit par rien faire alors l'industrie
ne veut pas cette imprévisibilité on a
créé le système qui va permettre
justement que si un projet à trouver
mais il veut gagner en corrigeant les
poches du sol on est toujours ouvert un
virage vers des petites des petites
améliorations mais en principe je pense
qu on a beaucoup amélioré le système qui
était déjà je n'allais pas redonner aux
provinces le droit exclusif de faire les
évaluations environnementales veut
éviter le dédoublement on veut on veut
simplifier le processus
et ça c'est des conversations qu'on est
en train d'avoir avec les provinces et
que j'ai eue aujourd'hui d'ailleurs avec
monsieur legault michaels pas mort et
michael kovak trois cent soixante huit
jours aujourd'hui dans des geôles
chinoises
l'an dernier je vous avais demandé
pourquoi vous prenez pas le téléphone
que vous appelez pas le président
chinois s'était pas la bonne question à
vous poser la vraie question à vous
poser c'est est-ce que monsieur tron ne
vous a pas laissé tomber parce que hier
il annonçait sabrent le champagne avec
les chinois
tout va bien les accords commerciaux et
nos canadiens sont encore en jaune at il
fait ce qu'il aurait dû faire c'est à
dire vraiment mettre la pression pour
les sorties je comprends que c'est une
prestation que nous avons que nous avons
tous de voir si canadien encore un prix
en détention arbitraire ah ah parce
qu'on a respecté une entente avec les
états unis et dans mes rencontres avec
le président y compris récemment à
londres
on a vraiment insisté sur ce point là et
les américains sont en train de
travailler sur cet enjeu là
effectivement j'aurais aimé pouvoir les
voir libérés hier avant-hier il ya une
semaine il ya dix mois
mais on va continuer de faire tout ce
qu'on peut pour le faire et comme tom
vous savez vous m'aviez posé cette
question là il ya six mois à une
rencontre du g20 j'ai eu une
conversation directe avec le président j
et par la suite on a eu des discussions
qui ont mené à adé a plus de discussions
mais c'est comme ça malheureusement que
jusqu'au l'occident va laisser aller les
chinois ya les ouigours des camps
d'internement ya un million cinq cent
mille personnes certains pensent qu'un
encore plus on a l'impression qu'on a
abdiqué
les démocraties occidentales puis bombay
à grands pas ce qu'on fait de l'argent
avec les chinois c'est ça rapporte
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire c'est une
question plus large qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire
d'abord je peux vous dire que dans les
rencontres que nos pays occidentaux
alliés ont eues avec les chinois depuis
un an
ils ont tous soulevé la question des
deux canadiens
et oui ça irrite et les chinois qui
disait arrêtés nous en parler c'est
passé de ses potes vos affaires parce
que les nippes et l'occident
reconnaissent que c'est un moment où il
faut se tenir ensemble pour dire non
c'est pas correct ce que vous êtes en
avance et ça marche pas même parce que
la chine a énormément de pression
interne
une représentant le marché qui est
important pour bien des gens on est tous
on a toujours du équilibré ou ou faire
en même temps une représentation pour
les droits de la personne tout en
voulant avoir des avantages économiques
ça toujours été un équilibre difficile
peut-être pour commencer à arriver un
moment où il va falloir faire des choix
difficiles mais on n'est pas tout à fait
là encore est ce que vous regrettez
d'avoir arrêté là vice président de
huawei non je ne regrette pas d'avoir
suivi une entente internationale qu'on
avait signé on n'a pas le droit de tout
simplement de façon arbitraire hadopi
qu'il ferait mais nous au canada
on respecte la loi et on en avait une
entente d'extradition mais elle est dans
sa ville la porte en lna sa villa et lit
des romans ali la littérature pedneault
deux canadiens sont dans des geôles on
l'a enlevé les lunettes à un démagogue
désir normes et c'est quelque chose
qu'on souligne régulièrement avec
meilleure protection pour les gens
malades je vous avais posé la question
en 2016 vous étiez engagé devant moi
dire on va le faire des profits encore
on s'est engagés 26 semaines dans la
plateforme
là on est en train de travailler
là-dessus
à présent on va voir ce devrait être
bientôt mais on entend aussi j'ai
rencontré de manama et
une autre aussi qui m'ont dit ça devrait
être encore plus et on est quant à elle
50 50 on regarde ses neiges soyons donc
il ya toujours des conséquences cette
décision mais on est en train de prendre
très au sérieux leurs demandes et on va
réfléchir à ce qu'on peut face à tarbes
m'aviez dit en 2016 pour les ministres
et médicale à mourir
sera t'elle est large la cour nous a dit
qu'il va et qu'il fallait l'élargir nous
on est en réflexion de quelle est la
meilleure façon de le faire parce que
évidemment faut toujours équilibrer la
protection des plus vulnérables et le
respect des droits de tout le monde
on voit aussi attardé les meilleurs
golfeurs
on va on va prendre la bonne décision
j'ai un sujet sur lequel vous avez
évolué depuis qu'on s'est vu la dernière
fois c'est la taxe garonne internet et
ps ont beaucoup de gens vous disent
allez-y là vous avez digéré
à quel moment il y aura d'abord la
position de la tps et la taxe sur les
chiffres d'affaires pour les jets les
positions de la tps on va faire très
bientôt je devrais peut-être dans le
prochain budget là on est en train de
regarder mais aussi c'est le sauve est
très bientôt pour les attaques sur les
gaffes
on est en train de travailler avec le cd
c'est un peu une problématique qui
revient partout où on veut pas
nécessairement s'avancer trop loin trop
rapidement comme un peu fait la france
ah si une solution plus que ma volée
mais c'est aussi les rémois de vous
couper mais votre minus a dit cette
semaine monsieur guilbeault on
n'attendra pas le cd est nécessairement
là je pense qu'on est très conscient de
ce qui c'est en train de se passer
peut-être qu'il y en a qui vont aller
avant d'autres mais on veut et elle
signé avec avec le seigneur
oh ça c'est nouveau parce que monsieur
legault pense également il le dit
qu'elle lui fournit donc là vous dites
on va attendre le rapport ces tpe on va
attendre le rapport au steak on va voir
comment on va on va s'avancer sur tout
nouvel an notre ses nouveaux murs on
s'était engagés à le faire pendant la
campagne électorale
on va le faire pour le times on est en
train de réfléchir
le rapport qui a été commandé à l' ocde
que je pense que et peut-être qu'il ya
un pré-rapport on peut savoir qu'est-ce
qui va revenir on peut prévoir ce qu'il
va faire mais on va le faire de façon
responsable
j'ai déjà dépensé mon terme ce premier
joyau ce faire vous et votre famille
toujours un plaisir pas merci à la
prochain merci